when I first booted up high on life for
the first time I knew what I was getting
myself into I'm familiar with not only
the work of Justin Roiland but also his
game Studio squanch games so I had an
idea of the sort of Comedy that was
coming my way but I did not expect
however was a 3D shooter with
metroidvania Vibes that Echo some of the
best games of my youth and more
importantly does them Justice
[Music]
high on life tells the story of an
unnamed protagonist whom everyone calls
Bounty Hunter even their own sister
fighting against a drug cartel that's
invaded Earth the cartel wishes to round
up every human on the planet and sell
them as the drug which other aliens can
consume via elaborate machines our
Bounty Hunter hero is armed with
galleons a race of talking guns and each
Galleon possesses its own attacks and
abilities the concept is admittedly very
weird but it's a well-told story that
kept me guessing until the end at this
point it Bears acknowledging that this
is 100 a Justin Roiland project complete
with all the Hallmarks of his comedic
philosophy rapid fire monologues fart
jokes demolition of the fourth wall
ad-libs and dark humor it's all
intertwined within the game's narrative
and presentation if things like Rick and
Morty Trover saves the universe or solar
opposites aren't your cup of tea then
this won't be either that said I have a
very high tolerance for this sort of
goofiness and I found myself laughing
throughout the 10 hour Adventure I got a
kick out of the fact that squanch games
licensed four full-length b-movies for
players to enjoy simply because it could
every time a voice actor in clear ad-lib
mode would laugh in the middle of a
diatribe I would also laugh the
referential comedy also got a reaction
out of me particularly mentions of other
video games
okay you know what it looks like some
simple platforming you know like but
you'd see in like Lucky's tail on uh you
know or um you know that one uh that one
game that we that we all know and love
Mario Land or whatever
there's a genuine charm in all of it
sure some of the jokes don't land in the
rambling of the gun in your hand can
sometimes go on too long but it's clear
in every attempt that the development
team was having fun making high on life
I never knew what was gonna happen next
as the scene progressed and that lack of
predictability enhanced The Experience
honestly this unruly approach is the
only way certain jokes can work which
includes for example an entire scene
that plays out in space Applebee's
however squanch games also knows this
brand of humor isn't for everyone and it
provides the option to tone down banter
so those turned off by consonant chatter
can still enjoy the game I left my
settings to frequent banter and didn't
think it was too too much in comparison
I didn't find the banter to be as
egregious as what earned Horizon
forbidden West criticism earlier this
year this could be because the
characters weren't speaking aloud about
puzzles in front of me which made the
dialogue feel more natural for the
setting but once you get past the
goofiness and focus on the game itself
high on life delivers a solid 3D shooter
experience that emulates the exploits of
Samus Iran each of the different biomes
I explored were brimming with secrets
from living chests filled with gold to
random NPCs offering a quick Zinger or a
brief side quest as the game progresses
vertical movement is introduced thanks
to finding a jet pack and that opens up
exploration even more these worlds are
large as well which the game tries to
counter with a waypoint system that
allows you to see which direction your
objective lies and how far it sits
sometimes this system gets its wires
crossed though and reaching one-way
points somehow turned into me returning
to the Waypoint I just came from but
more often than not a simple tap of the
d-pad pointed me back in the right
direction the waypoints also become
somewhat of a crutch in the later parts
of the game as not using them sometimes
led me to traveling to the wrong part of
the map and getting lost it's not a
perfect system but the waypoints are
helpful more often than not the galleons
each stand out from one another both in
their quips and how they're used in
combat Kenny is the resonant pistol Gus
is the shotgun knifey is the uh knife
and Sweezy acts as the Needler from Halo
the most interesting of the weapons is
creature which acts as a sort of Pikmin
device launching small creatures at
enemies for damage over time all four
are potent in combat as they possess
advantages over certain foes and make it
essential to switch through guns during
a fight each gun has a second power that
aids with traveling and environmental
puzzles which slowly opened more of the
world to me as I progressed Kenny issues
blast of thick slime which will hit
designated obstacles and allow you to
pass Sweezy can fire a shot that slows
time in the area where it lands making
her the perfect choice to get past fast
spinning fans that would otherwise cause
damage these special shots can be used
in fights as well Kenny's slime shots
will launch enemies into the air for
extra hits for example which gave me
even more options using the gatlions in
battle is a lot of fun and the enemies
fit right into the weird and silly
aesthetic of the rest of the game the
bad guys are each covered in a sort of
yellow goo the origin of which I won't
spoil and as you deal damage the goo
wears off exposing their gray bodies
underneath while strange it serves as an
easy visual aid to how much damage
you've done to a certain enemy and it
also allows you to create your own weak
points so say an enemy is hiding behind
cover and there's a patch of gray skin
Exposed on its arm targeting that spot
will make the enemy fall more quickly
it's an ingenious idea of showing combat
damage on enemies without giving them
health bars or something similar that
said most of the enemies I encountered
are dumb as rocks I could run up to any
of the normal Grunts and either shoot or
melee them to death without taking a lot
of damage but there were times where I
was overwhelmed and had to retry a
battle but those were more due to me
being overzealous than enemies
outsmarting me boss fights aren't much
better as the majority of them boil down
to Simply shooting and dodging some of
them shake things up a bit whether they
Implement a special shot of The Gatlin
you're about to rescue or they give you
multiple bosses to fight at once but at
their core it's more of the same combat
you get from the grunch just with bigger
baddies while overall combat is fun
where it feels tedious is the length of
some of the skirmishes each encounter
tends to play out in waves with one or
two sets of enemies coming out before
the battle is over some of them stretch
far longer than that to the point where
Kenny the pistol says here we go again
and I'm feeling exactly the same these
fights become a test of patience as well
as a test of skill boss fights don't
have this issue for the most part but
some of them fall into their own issues
one fight in particular still makes me
angry just thinking about how difficult
it became in its final stage ultimately
high on life is in its own weird way a
take on what a modern Metroid Prime game
could be through the lens of Justin
roiling's comedy Antics there's a
similar sense of exploration mixed with
fast-paced moments of combat only here
it's also swelling with expletive Laden
jokes and sometimes incoherent rambling
the story offbeat as it may be is told
incredibly well with characters and
moments I'll be referencing for a while
even if you're not a fan of the kind of
humor that high on life presents the
game that's here is worth the trip
hey uh my name is Thomas schnitzel and I
just want to say I didn't kidnap that
alien baby the trial wasn't publicized
it wasn't on air like nobody saw it I I
was I was pronounced Innocent but nobody
really saw it so I I'm I'm buying these
commercials to just make sure everyone
knows I did not kidnap the alien baby I
did not do it